everybody this is just a little extra
help on figuring out wind direction and
so if you're just given a let's say in
this case all I have is a high-pressure
Center and let's say I've got a city
here and I've got a city here now how do
I figure out the wind direction so I
have to know if it's northern hemisphere
or southern hemisphere so let's just say
this is northern hemisphere so I know
I've got clockwise rotation around a
high in the northern hemisphere so what
what you imagine is this circle that's
centered on the H that's coming around
passing right through say a and then
another circle that's coming around
that's passing right through B okay now
when we're figuring out wind ultimately
what we have to do is draw a straight
line segment because what we want the
goal is that is to say the wind is
blowing from the north west or south we
need a single direction so it's not good
enough to say that the the wind is
curved we want to know what is the
direction exactly at that point so this
is if you remember tangents from math
write a tangent of a circle this is what
we're drawing so here the tangent to
that circle at that point would be that
so it's clockwise winds I know the winds
come in this direction and it comes
around and passes through a you'll
become exactly from the north and wind
is always described in the direction is
coming from so this would be a north
wind so if I asked you what you know
describe the direction you would say
north
what would the direction be city B well
exactly the same thing because you still
have this cone around this is a tangent
to the circle at that point also north
and in fact any city I have here along
this line these would all be north winds
difference might be the speed but we're
not trying to figure out the speed all
we can do is figure out the direction
here so let's pick another one let's say
I said okay what's the wind direction
here okay and again northern hemisphere
so I figure okay this is I you know
again think of a circle centered in the
center of the H and I've got a clockwise
rotation around the H what's the tangent
at that point might look like this
where's that wind coming from it's
coming from the south west right it's
coming from this area down there so this
would be a south west wind so again when
we describe when it's the direction it's
coming from okay so let's do say another
example and let's say I've got a low and
I've got a high okay all right so let's
say I've got a city let's say right here
okay
so what do I do and again if this is
northern hemisphere counterclockwise
think of it think of a circle going
around the low and it's going to be
going counterclockwise so you'll be
coming to kind of right through here and
what's the tangent of that circle at
that point like this in which direction
is it coming from
it's coming from that it's coming from
this direction which is south east so
this is a south east wind now if you've
got multiple pressure centers like a
high and a low and I've got something in
the middle and I want to know well which
direction is it do I use the high or the
low if I use the low I imagine a circle
that's centered on the low
coming this way so I'm gonna draw that
okay and if I imagine the hi let me just
have a Harrow to that if I imagine it
coming around the hi I would have an arc
go in this direction
okay so clockwise are on the high
counterclockwise are on the low the
tangent to either one of those is the
same answer so in this case it's from
the south west so if you've got a high
and a low and you have a point in the
middle it doesn't matter how you think
of it you'll get the same answer now
what if I had a high and a high okay and
I got a point right here so if you've
got two of the same pressure go with the
one you're closest to I'm closest to
this one so I'm going to use the
clockwise move rotation around the high
draw my tangent okay and then I'd have
an answer that's from the north west
that's a northwest wind I will not give
you one that's exactly in the middle
because that one's actually you know
you'd have to have more information to
solve it because one of them would be
going clockwise and going from one way
and the other one would be coming around
clockwise the other way and they cancel
each other out so realistically what
happens is there's basically no wind in
the middle we didn't get into that
doesn't matter okay so if you've got
more than one pressure center go towards
the one that's closest that's usually
just the rule to remember okay so so
that's how you do it if you don't have
any contour lines if you do have contour
lines
the contour lines is the same thing
except you'd know more information
because the contour lines help you help
guide you so on this one let's see so
I've got a low right here in fact it's
kind of split into two here so I'll just
kind of put try this it's got it hello
it's really kind of it's one single low
but it's kind of broke it up into two
blobs but all you need to know is that
because this is a low and I'm in the
northern hemisphere
I've got counterclockwise circulation
and what we said in this class is that
we're gonna assume the wind was parallel
to the contour lines so I draw a little
wiggle straight segments again these are
like tangents to the contour lines going
around and then if I asked you say you
know what is the you know what is the
wind direction right here you would say
well it's from the North West right
that's a northwest wind and if you were
over here on the high so here I've got
these numbers are getting larger towards
the center so this is an H right there
and so I've got clockwise rotation
around a high in the northern hemisphere
so I know I've got wind coming this way
and I just draw on little straight
segments okay or if I was between
contours same thing just stay parallel
to the contours right so again if I
asked you you know what's the what's the
wind right here this one would be from
the south west
that's a southwest wind so the
difference the only difference between
these and the one that we just did is
that here you don't have any additional
information so you're assuming the winds
are going circular around them when we
have sea level pressure maps that
contours give us some more information
we can see that it's not perfectly a
perfectly circular circulation but it's
kind of this weird egg-shaped thing okay
so I hope that helped if we if you get
one that's in the southern hemisphere
just remember the rules are reversed
so around the hi in the southern
hemisphere counterclockwise around the
low in the southern hemisphere clockwise
all right